hello and welcome to this video saying
chromis if she rated lower than him you
know something's wrong he I just have a
good score against and usually win but
he outranks me at the moment so what is
he going to do c4 that's rare in the
skin disposition with the pawn are you
serious
what is that
okay if I go to b6 he might play ecigs I
mean I don't know and it looks like
looks bad really but I can also Dohee
a.m. that's not bad just prevent
anything like that so go e6 is currently
not so easily playing f5
I thought you would cause c5
get to a fairly unclear position my
structure is excellent but I've got less
space and my development is also
somewhat questionable so you can also go
here I don't know really
let's start with this
it's not so easy to get a concrete
counter clay I mean I've got good
squares like g7 to f5 and so on 95 but
that's not a real counter play I just
have squares I mean I think this is okay
but it's not it's not super obvious
where my activities coming from later
[Music]
okay so my pieces are okay Knight f5
those Knights are nice but again it's
not quite clear with my active planners
I would really really really like to
trade Queens em that would be nice I'm
not really intending to take any of
those pawns my ideas roopd 87 Queen d8
queen of 1886 I know it sounds like it's
a pretty pretty long plan but so maybe
hey I can do something here and III kind
of invites this
okay so is he threatening something
directly we should have 5ef queen takes
maybe but is that that really takes a
long time
so is he threatening something now Luke
age five maybe
so if I take on b3 route h5
hey this is dangerous
if I play I would need more time yeah
absolutely
teenage aid or something
now I distinguish anyway and with the
time I made sure I played 97 secure f5
even more on the likelihood that here
something here is pretty high
I mean you basically plays without the
e3 Bishop but if I'm not nated I'm
winning strategically but I probably get
mated
I currently don't see how to be honest
but clean age 43 clean a tree or
something this is slow but it might be
working create want X loop chain 3 this
one what is that threatening hook h5 yes
time morning
I go back with the cool
one-take screen takes is safe absolutely
safe okay so this this is who Sochi to
be winning now but still have to do it
okay
I just blended this friggin con check
okay it's not a big deal let's just pure
luck check check check
why forfeit on time yes sir one on time
the end the position is also good you
have landed g6 that was it was really
completely unnecessary Here I am winning
strategically he's got to complicate
with the pawn structure is just so
terrible that it will that will rot
maybe enough to lose it was tough here
and in this kind of position I mean from
a purely structural point of view this
is
hashtag he's got the double pawn deform
the bishop 23 years not good but he's
got space and he's got Taking Chances
the engine action gives me an edge which
is kind of surprising I mean I don't
know I felt this is dangerous quindi
fire that's an interesting move but okay
this is also very natural for those
nights there the engine like smacks my
position
look ft 8 even better and now King h8
a.m. that that's the normal move them to
to get out of this tactic and
potentially have 97 as well maybe this
is a this is better I am yeah this is
expected this but then I'm pretty
quickly I am this is a tempo and yeah
the engine likes my position a lot so I
I found the defense that engine also
gives a queen 7 was a bit stronger it
yeah so here it's a it's winning but you
have to still do it I was really out for
the Queen trade yeah I know I should
play with e6 but it's going to be not
not that difficult technically because
almost all endgame types are winning or
close to it so
yeah we had a time scramble then after I
run that the phone is probably equal
okay
ministry spawns are completely worthless
so taking would be suicidal I have to
have to stay put it at the end I one
more time okay guys thanks for watching